2016 has been a long, brutal year for celebrity
deaths.
In addition to the loss of renowned musicians
such as David Bowie and Prince, many screen
stars have also died this year, from cherished
character actors to major movie stars.
Here's a look back at the actors and actresses
who passed away in 2016.
Alan Rickman
After joining the Royal Shakespeare Company
in England in the 1970s, Alan Rickman broke
out on the big screen in 1988, at the relatively
advanced age of 41 — but what a breakthrough
role it was.
Playing the evil Hans Gruber in Die Hard set
in motion a career of playing some of Hollywood's
most iconic screen villains, such as the Sheriff
of Nottingham in Robin Hood: Prince of Thieves,
Judge Turpin in Sweeney Todd, and the secret
good guy Professor Severus Snape in all eight
Harry Potter movies.
Rickman died at age 69 after a battle with
pancreatic cancer.
Gene Wilder
Few would disagree that Gene Wilder was a
comic genius.
His collaborations with director Mel Brooks
were especially fruitful, spawning his memorable
turns in The Producers, Blazing Saddles, and
Young Frankenstein.
"That's Frankenstein."
That would be enough of a legacy for any actor,
but Wilder also played the title role in Willy
Wonka and the Chocolate Factory and starred
in three buddy comedy movies with Richard
Pryor, cementing his status as a true screen
legend.
In August 2016, when Wilder died at the age
of 83 from complications from Alzheimer's
disease, his passing was quite unexpected.
He'd apparently concealed his condition from
the public because the actor "simply couldn't
bear the idea of one less smile in the world."
Anton Yelchin
This Russian-American actor was just beginning
to emerge as a major young talent, earning
critical praise for his work in Green Room
and the Star Trek franchise, among other films.
But he tragically passed away at the age of
27 when his vehicle rolled down his driveway
and pinned him against a brick pillar in a
bizarre accident at his home.
Peter Vaughan
This tireless character actor was probably
best known to American audiences as Maester
Aemon on Game of Thrones, but he was also
an accomplished star of film and TV for decades
before he joined the HBO fantasy series.
His standout roles in British comedies and
cult classic films made him a star in his
homeland before he traveled anywhere near
The Wall.
He was 93.
Garry Shandling
One of the most prominent stand-up comedians
of the 1980s, and a pioneer of the observational
comedy style, Garry Shandling went on to co-create
and star in two of the most forward-thinking
TV comedies ever made: his self-titled sitcom
and his mockumentary style dramedy The Larry
Sanders Show.
Shandling would go on to make a formidable
big screen career for himself too, but it's
his TV work which made him a pop culture icon
before his death at his home at the age of
66.
Alan Thicke
Thanks to his memorable turn as the Seaver
family patriarch on TV's Growing Pains, Alan
Thicke was beloved as a parental figure for
many children of the '80s.
Alan Thicke was 69 when he passed, reportedly
after playing a game of hockey with his youngest
son.
Patty Duke
At the age of just 16, Patty Duke became the
youngest-ever Academy Award winner for her
role as Helen Keller in 1962's The Miracle
Worker, and a year later, she began her small
screen turn as "identical cousins" on the
self-titled Patty Duke Show.
Her career in film, television, and stage
would be long-lived, and she passed on her
acting gene to her son, Sean Astin of Lord
of the Rings fame.
Duke was also a vocal advocate for mental
illness awareness after being diagnosed with
bipolar disorder.
She died of sepsis at the age of 69.
Garry Marshall
While this Hollywood legend might be best
known for his work behind the lens, Garry
Marshall was also a memorable actor in his
time.
His boisterous personality made its way to
the big screen in Hocus Pocus and A League
of Their Own, along with a number of television
series.
Marshall died at the age of 81.
Kenny Baker
For Star Wars fans, Kenny Baker's face wasn't
the most recognizable part of his presence
— he was the actor who brought life to R2-D2
in six of the Star Wars films and became an
icon of that franchise.
Before visiting a galaxy far, far away, though,
he was known for his work as a circus clown
and comedian.
He was 81 when he passed away after a long
illness.
Jon Polito
If you've ever seen a Coen Brothers film,
chances are you've seen Jon Polito at his
best.
The long-working character actor appeared
in some of the directors' most acclaimed projects.
All told, Polito appeared in more than 100
movies and TV shows over the course of a three-decades-long
career and was 65 when he died of blood cancer.
Alexis Arquette
Transgender actress Alexis Arquette was a
prominent member of her acting family and
was memorable for her big screen roles in
Pulp Fiction and The Wedding Singer as well
as her activism for LGBTQ issues.
She was 47 when she passed away.
Robert Vaughn
Legendary small screen star Robert Vaughn
thrived for decades in the action show sphere.
He is perhaps best known for his work in The
Man from U.N.C.L.E. and The A-Team.
Vaughn was also among the first actors ever
to speak out about political views, working
with several anti-Vietnam War organizations
during his prime, and received a Ph.D. in
communications.
He was 83.
Ron Glass
With not one but two cult hits on the small
screen, Ron Glass is best known for his scene-stealing
work as Sergeant Harris in Barney Miller,
but sci-fi fans will probably know him best
for his role as Shepherd Book in the short-lived
and beloved series Firefly.
He was 71.
Alice Drummond
One of the most recognizable character actresses
of all time, Alice Drummond popped up in dozens
of movies and TV shows since the late '60s,
when she moved from the New York stage to
the screen.
One of her most famous appearances may have
been in the original Ghostbusters, but she
starred in dozens of films and TV shows before
passing away at the age of 88.
Margaret Whitton
Major League fans might remember Margaret
Whitton best for her turn as the mean team
owner Rachel Phelps, but in real life she
was an avid fan of the sport.
The actress worked on multiple media throughout
her career, including movies and the stage,
and was 67 when she died.
Zsa Zsa Gabor
A predecessor of Paris Hilton and Kim Kardashian,
Zsa Zsa Gabor pioneered the idea of being
"famous for being famous."
The Hungarian-born Gabor was married at least
eight times, almost always to wealthy tycoons
of one sort or another.
She still managed an acting career of sorts,
appearing in films and TV shows in the '50s
and '60s, such as the original Moulin Rouge,
and as the seductive Minerva on the campy
Batman.
After suffering from a series of illnesses
and injuries over the past few years, Gabor
passed away at the age of 99 on December 18.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!